Alright, so we've talked about Git and
GitHub, we've talked about how to use
GitHub and how to introduce changes to
projects but we haven't really talked
about how you would actually work on
those projects on your own computer in
your own text editor or IDE. To do that,
you need to clone the repository. Now,
we've talked about branching, we talked
about forking, so those are kind of ways
of making copies of code. When you
clone you're also making a copy of the
code. But first, let's talk about what
working locally means. When you're
working on github.com you're working
totally on what's called the remote
repository but part of what's cool about
Git is that it's distributed which means
you can have a copy of the entire
project on your own computer with no
network connection and continue your
work. But to do that you have to work
locally on your own machine. When you
clone you can do it easily from github.com
either in an IDE, in GitHub desktop
app, or using the terminal. That brings
down a copy to your local computer you
can still communicate with the remote
repository that will still be stored on
github.com. You'll have to sync these
changes manually, they don't happen
automatically, and also you should know
that your co-workers your colleagues are
also communicating with the remote
repository so when you push up changes
from your local copy of the repository
when you push those up to GitHub
someone else can pull those changes to
their own local environment and see your
changes or continue work. So just to
recap when you want to bring repository
down and work on it in your own
development environment, you'll clone the
repository.